American fighter jets are conducting
critical aerial exercises today in the
Arctic Circle the maneuvers are just a
few hundred miles from Russia which has
repeatedly sent warplanes close to US
airspace in recent weeks in the story
you'll see only on CBS News Charlie
d'Agata went flying with US forces
well good morning from the Arctic Circle
a long way from home for US Marines from
South Carolina but they're playing a
vital role in these war games against an
imaginary enemy that's all too real
veteran Marine pilot Lieutenant Colonel
Roy nikka has spent a career targeting
America's foes but on this exercise he
and his team are playing the role of the
enemy and we got the rare opportunity to
join them at full throttle the f-18
Hornet takes flight in seconds soaring
into the skies above the Arctic Circle
we refuel with a British RAF tanker
callsign Ascot before we reach the
combat scenario where these fighters
attempted to penetrate allied air
defenses the Thunderbolts or T bolts are
among the most elite forces taking part
in exercises involving the UK France
Germany Sweden Norway Finland Denmark
and the Netherlands a hundred 40
aircraft a thousand personnel united
against a common enemy even if that
enemy is unnamed the dogfight that
ensued is strictly classified but we the
bad guys lost it was all so quick you
know he heard hostiles coming off with
12 you were moving in we were surrounded
so this is about life that's why we died
we were surrounded nobody here is
mentioning neighboring Russia but Moscow
has been accused of jamming
communications and launching mock
attacks during previous exercises one
marine commander told us Russia should
be looking at these exercises as a
deterrent for CBS this morning Charlie
d'Agata Rovaniemi airbase Finland